in putting you have family assured leaving
home freijeiro
howard in japan
they are actually they are fine basic driven
to work was not as simple by jorge anti
family
[Music]
jorge and his wife email will make
documentary living in the car california
from here to the border we are two
hours and a half
then the express where the
migration
every time work on these roads the
risk sports jon
Y
[Music]
and I've been in the sun for 17 years
and I'm not a vandalism, I'm not a
junkie I'm not a rapist I'm not a
drug dealer
I am also a message that I make to
my latin people that of the face that is not
hide
that you do not owe anything
jorge animal the works several jobs
his arthritis
it's to put your point six million in
very large documents live in
california I work very hard and people
that I know also throw themselves 3 to
14 hours to be able to keep your
family what form of those that
times and salaries good but I want
they know how to go forward, nothing else they are carme
where I am because I want to have
my own banquet business and sometimes
we get a legal complaint of gardening
demolition of houses the person who says
that the Latino does not work is a lie
here it looks and it shows and I am one of the
people that I have to fight
jorge xiang sun is born in the west
Half of the tour by breaking nextel
bear stearns and are legal and the car
staying with you defer action for
three rivers robert green clean own
stake
precede trump be attentive take away
the legal status to the train and they stop being
of order is very frustrating because we do not
we expected
these decisions or this attitude of a
true president
a president although we are
here we are not citizens but also
we have rights and as human beings I
I think we also deserve respect and
this gentleman then
he has denigrated us very much they have loved us
trample us acquired humiliate jorge
open animal and children's drummers
combine one time document to be
part i did not have to do with
immigration for it is if we stop
they know I'm not going to talk said right
remain silent and until my
lawyer there is no problem
but independently even though they
take everything you do not sell anything
since they are told the rights are
says but sometimes blacks
like that pressed intimacy
because it happened with a compadre of mine and a
glass of water
they put the gun
and they said we're going to give you the water
the fire member
the papers
balbina document of acens indicated
wait for health game for his father
you work as a garden helper and
those that come from whatever
jonathan works at m 0
but they also work for our group
of little things we do outside of work
because because I want a better
education I believe that
like the money is not that we
we impose a career what I
I want you to study this is not what
they choose but it is a race
university
I want them to go ahead as I
I say to my wife two we will depend
neither of them when they grow up
because I want them to be free
have an American dream
heidfeld are indifferent from the dogout
immigration artist family and life
people keep word not documents
afraid
the latin monster has to wake up
to be the voice
that nothing else is to be
locked up and say is not that I'm afraid
or I do not want to get out of the shadows
you have to make your life as it should be
to be normal without fear if you know the
laws and regulations will be a regular life
up sounds
[Music]
ibanesto with celebrates the nation and the
province of blas
of houses in the Dominican document
immigrants doctors and work now that
the portal programs in limbo in euronext
video and ricardo